talk about epic cliffhangers over the
course of the season five finale of
AMC's better call saw plenty happened
but nothing was really resolved still
the episode ominously called something
unforgivable was overflowing with
important developments let's break down
exactly what happened rattled by the
fallout from their tense confrontation
with Lalo and the rest of the Salamanca
cartel Jimmy and Kim decide to cool off
for a couple days at a local ritzy hotel
after their first night hiding out Jimmy
makes his first of several half-hearted
appeals to Kim urging her to leave him
and though Jimmy claims it's the last
time he'll make the mistake of getting
involved with organized crime he doesn't
seem to have a way to get out and he
knows it
despite Jimmy's overtures kim heads out
in the morning to work where she's
accosted by her former boss Howard
Hamlin Howard tells Kim about the
bowling balls Jimmy used to destroy his
car and the prostitutes Jimmy sent to
disrupt a business lunch and suggest
that Jimmy's influence has already hurt
her and that's it despite is nameste
license plate it's pretty clear that
Howard still assumes that every lawyer
is in it for the money
Jimmy has to be manipulating Kim into
quitting her high-profile client after
all why else would Kim ditch her
corporate law job to take on pro bono
work Howard's accusation crosses the
line and back in the hotel Kim and Jimmy
jokingly spar back and forth with
increasingly elaborate plots to destroy
Howard Hamlin until things get serious
when if Howard does something terrible
Kim proposes setting Hamlin up for some
kind of misconduct that might result in
a career setback anything from
disbarment or imprisonment which would
force his law firm to settle the
Sandpiper case in haste viewers will
remember that the Sandpiper case is the
massive class action lawsuit that Jimmy
initiated on the first season of better
call Saul and passed off to Hamlet's HHM
for a referral fee once that case
settles or reaches a verdict jimmy is
entitled to roughly two million dollars
but what Kim is suggesting is criminal
conspiracy the likes of which even
slippin Jimmy is taken aback by Kim's
journey has always been a moral
tug-of-war between Jimmy and Howard
while Kim has been drifting toward Jimmy
all along she's always kept one cautious
foot in Hamlet's world until
now now she's all in on slippin Jimmy
McGill as a way of finding her own pro
bono law practice for better or worse
and was season 6 being the final season
for soul what better way to close the
circle on this conflict than to bring it
all the way back to Sandpiper it all
begs the question however why do we
never hear about Kim and Breaking Bad
committing a crime in the name of a
greater good doesn't have a history of
working out well in the Breaking Bad
universe the more action-packed half of
the episode takes place in Mexico where
nacho Varga has been suddenly enlisted
to help execute Lalo Salamanca in his
own beautiful home Varga spends most of
the episode quietly pretending that he
wants to join the salamanca cartel Lalo
seems eager enough to take him under his
wing and even introduces him to the big
boss who ultimately approves of the new
recruit
Vargas faced about all of this build-up
is as inscrutable as ever
he's either having some serious second
thoughts about taking out Lalo or on the
verge of throwing up from the pressure
Varga has only one job leave the back
door to the Salamanca compound open so
the Gus Springs outlaw SWAT team can get
inside to assassinate Lalo he manages to
get to the door in time and escape but
the assassination team bungles the hit
voilá escapes through a secret tunnel
then circles back to pick off the hitmen
who infiltrated his home
of course the ten of you was likely knew
Lalo survived Jimmy was still terrified
that Lalo was after him during the
events of Breaking Bad
now Lalo knows exactly who wants him
dead enough to violate the sanctity of
his home bring mic Jimmy and Varga all
better be on notice except how will they
ever know as far as anyone in America
knows the hit was complete that's going
to render everyone sitting ducks when
Lalo inevitably returns and the
Salamanca's bring war across the border
we know Jimmy Mike and Gus surviving to
the events of Breaking Bad but where's
Kim
the finale apps for the cliffhanger
ending but we can all anticipate what's
ahead
better call Saul is renewed for a sixth
and final season which should return to
AMC sometime in 2021 check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
shows are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]